und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf uns marietta slomka
guten abend wenn sich in berlin boden
die führungsgremien der cdu treffen
werden das wieder schwierige schulkreise
die partei sucht haltung ziel und
führung das einzige woran es ihr im
moment nicht mangelt sind interessenten
für die führungsposten eine ganze riege
von männern die sich für geeignet halten
und die sich aus ihrem jeweiligen
schützengräben heraus belauern und teils
auch beschließen dass politik ein hartes
geschäft ist wusste man wie gnadenlos
mit verlegern umgegangen wird weiß
inzwischen auch armin laschet seitdem er
sich selbst aber etwas aus der
schusslinie genommen hat geraten andere
stärker ins blickfeld wie das ausgehen
wird weiß im moment wohl noch niemand
mathis feldhoff zur lage der union
es ist eine symbolische szene am freitag
im bundesrat es wird einsam um den noch
ministerpräsidenten und noch
parteivorsitzenden armin laschet
die die ins kandidaten amt gehoben haben
die die ihn unterstützt haben und die
die ihn verhindern wollten alten abstand
der kampf um die neuaufstellung der cdu
hat längst begonnen
morgen laschet sagen was er sich
vorstellt einen sonderparteitag einen
moderierten übergang aber hören wollen
dass nur wenige laschet ist auf abruf
und in der union tobt das chaos was wir
nicht brauchen es zerlegung
selbstzerfleischung die fortsetzung
dessen was wir über den gesamten
wahlkampf erlebt haben wir sind von 30
auf 24 prozent gefallen durch die art
und weise wie armin laschet eben nicht
unterstützt wurde appelle die verhallen
friedrich merz rechnen mit csu-chef
söder ab der wahlkampf sei der tiefpunkt
unserer zusammenarbeit und unseres
umgangs miteinander
stillos respektlos und streckenweise
rüpelhaft söder gewesen der so
angesprochene wollte schon gestern
nichts von einer eigenen schuld wissen
aber seit laschets rückzug richtet sich
der scheinwerfer halt auch auf ihn dass
einige sagen sie hätten armin laschet ra
demontiert
das ist unsinn doch in seiner rede vor
der jungen union bayern kann er dann
doch nicht an sich halten als hätte er
auch zwei wochen nach der wahl noch
phantomschmerzen am ende wollten die
schulden die deutschen einen anderen
kanzlerkandidaten als den cdu/csu
aufgestellt
söder droht zu überziehen das geht
selbst seiner treusten truppe inzwischen
zu weit in der antragsberatung sucht die
basis ein ventil
wir würden hier was dann schreiben
stefan wir streichen markus söder der
antrag den das betrifft es nicht so
wichtig das symbol ist es schon wir
sehen keine ein-mann-partei wir sind die
csu und die sind wie wir sind die orte
fahren und es ist nicht nur der
christian sondern es sind wir alle und
es macht uns stark söder ist nicht mehr
unumstritten auch nicht in der csu 75
prozent stimmen für die streichung
seines namens bei der cdu positionieren
sich mögliche kandidaten norbert röttgen
daniel günther jens spahn carsten
linnemann ralph brinkhaus friedrich merz
insbesondere die ost verbände wollen
jetzt mitreden die basis einbeziehen den
machtkampf in der partei mitbestimmen
sie muss nur darauf achten dass sie
nicht wie zuletzt den eindruck erwirbt
dass man sich über die interessenlage
weiter teile der basis unserer parteien
weg setzt im saarland versuchten sie
gestern diesen interessen gerecht zu
werden zwei altgediente minister
annegret kramp karrenbauer peter
altmaier ziehen sich zurück wir haben
sichergestellt dass der
generationswechsel statt findet zu einem
zeitpunkt wo es notwendiger ist denn je
die union steht vor turbulenten tagen
rücktritten und kandidaturen ein
ungemütlicher herbst für die partei
und darüber wollen wir mit norbert
lammert sprechen der die union die cdu
natürlich in und auswendig kennt war
zwölf jahre lang bundestagspräsident und
ist jetzt chef der
konrad-adenauer-stiftung guten abend
ellermann
guten antworten die konrad adenauer
stiftung ist ja auch so eine art
thinktank die die partei beobachtet
vielleicht auch berät situationen
analysiert was sagen sie in der
momentanen situation angesichts all
dieser kämpfe und der frage wie man da
wieder rauskommen sollte jetzt möglichst
schnell ein neuer chef bestimmt werden
damit die richtung klar ist oder sollte
man sich damit eher zeit lassen
also mich überrascht ein bisschen oder
jedenfalls mich irritiert dass manche in
der partei offenkundig die schnelligkeit
der wahl eines neuen vorsitzenden oder
besser gleich des ganzen vorstandes für
noch wichtiger halten als die
sorgfältige aufarbeitung
einer
grundlegend neuen lage für die union
für die wir uns zwar sicher nicht ewig
lange zeit nehmen können aber die
notwendige zeit sicher nehmen müssen
manche haben offensichtlich noch nicht
so richtig zur kenntnis genommen dass
vorletzten sonntag abend nicht nur eine
16 jährige amtszeit einer bedeutenden
kanzlerin zu ende gegangen ist was
ohnehin natürlich eine zäsur darstellt
sondern dass das wahlergebnis
ganz sicher
der historische dimension in der
geschichte der union also immerhin über
75 jahre hat da ist ja geradezu ein
tsunami durch die partei gefahren
und
wenn manche jetzt schon genau zu wissen
meinen dass kein stein mehr auf dem
anderen bleibt dann ist für den
vermeintlichen
räumungsverkauf ja doch auch darüber
nachzudenken ob sich in diesem
zusammenhang das ein oder andere
wertvolle stück nicht doch suchen und
finden lässt es scheint so um ihren
begriff räumungsverkauf aufzunehmen dass
die partei aber auch so ein wenig nach
ihrem markenkern sucht und in welches
regal sie denn was stellen will die
einen sagen also wir haben 2017 an die
afg verloren das war der große fehler
die anderen sagen schaut man hin diesmal
haben wir an spd am meisten stimmen
verloren also die merkel wähler laufen
uns davon irgendeine richtung scheint
sich die partei entscheiden zu wollen
jedenfalls müssen diese fragen
beantwortet werden und ganz offenkundig
beantworten sie sich nicht von selbst
die allermeisten haben ja für ihre von
ihnen gerade beispielhaft vorgetragenen
positionen
in der regel auch beachtliche argumente
die wiederum von anderen nicht geteilt
werden also einen jedenfalls
eindrucksvolleren beleg für die
notwendigkeit eines gründlichen
nachdenkens kann es ja schwerlich geben
als wenn ein und dieselben befunde ein
und derselbe wahlergebnis in einer
ersten spontanen sicht bei vielen zu
ganz unterschiedlichen
spontanen schlussfolgerungen führt und
wie kann man das dann nicht spontan
sondern strukturiert machen
also ich fand unter vielerlei
gesichtspunkten die initiative des
amtierenden parteivorsitzenden nicht nur
respektabel sondern auch klug
die notwendigkeit eines neuanfangs
selber zu annoncieren es mit der
ankündigung zu verbinden dass er selber
sicher nicht für diesen neuanfang die
richtige
führungspersonen ist und anzubieten
einen solchen prozess zu moderieren
mir fällt es auch schwer jedenfalls
wieder spontan
dafür eine bessere konstruktion eine
geeignetere person zu finden als einen
gewählten amtierenden parteivorsitzenden
der seine bereitschaft für genau diesen
prozess ausdrücklich erklärt hat herr
lammert wenn wir diese woche die auch
wieder erlebnisreich war uns ansehen
dann sehen wir in österreich nebenan
sebastian kurz der
gefallene star der svp cvp die an
zwischen liste kurz heißt war ja einer
ähnlichen situation wird die deutsche
union cdu mann war schon länger nicht
mehr ein mann verlor das kanzleramt mann
verlor junge wähler und dann kommt da so
ein junger fan mit einem gewissen hang
zum rechtspopulismus und verspricht
plötzlich einen sensationellen
wiederaufstieg viele in ihrer partei
gerade die jüngeren haben gesagt also
ein wie sebastian kurz bräuchten wir
auch glauben sie dass das jetzt immer
noch gesagt wird oder gibt es da bei
einigen vielleicht ein umdenken
der wesentliche und ein ganz
wesentlicher unterschied zwischen der
deutschen und der österreichischen
situation auch und gerade ein
wesentlicher unterschied zwischen der
svp und der cdu besteht darin dass die
union nie einen parteivorsitzenden
geschweige denn kanzlerkandidaten
gewählt hat der im verdacht des
rechtspopulismus steht
zu den lektionen die wir nicht nur in
deutschland aber auch aus jüngeren
wahlergebnissen nehmen gehört aber genau
dieser einsicht dass die popularität
solcher kandidaten in der wählerschaft
ausgeprägter ist als in beachtlichen
teilen auch unserer partei und wie man
genau mit dieser diskrepanz und den sich
damit verbundenen erwartungen und
befürchtungen und hoffnungen umgehen
muss gehört zu den vielen fragen bei
denen ich noch mal nur dringlich
empfehlen kann darauf nicht eine
möglichst schnelle sondern eine
möglichst durchdachte antwort zu bilden
herr lammert danken für das gespräch
gerne
das interview haben wir aufgezeichnet
wie es in deutschland insgesamt
politisch weitergehen wird das
interessiert nicht nur uns das wird auch
im ausland sehr genau beobachtet
deutschland spielt in der welt kritik ja
eine rolle in europa sowieso und das
nicht nur als wirtschaftsmacht hinzu kam
die lange regierungszeit von angela
merkel sie hat viele andere
regierungschefs und chefinnen kommen und
gehen sehen und war für viele neulinge
die elder statesman deren wort gewicht
hat
2017 nach der wahl von donald trump
gehörte die new york times ja sogar zur
führerin der freien welt ob dass man
eine überzogene erwartung war die man da
in die deutsche kanzlerin setzte auf
jeden fall zeigt es dass es anderen
nicht egal ist wer im berliner
kanzleramt sitzt das konnte man auch
heute spüren bei merkels abschiedsbesuch
in israel welche erfahrungen berichtet
so einen ehrendoktor gehört fast schon
zum guten ton für politiker auf
auslandsreise doch die verleihung heute
steht zum abschied symbolhaft für
bewunderung respekt und dank eines
ganzen landes wohl kein deutscher
politiker war in israel jesu beliebt wie
die bundeskanzlerin sie gilt als treue
gefährtin und kämpferin gegen
antisemitismus
ich begrüße mit angela merkel eine treue
freundin des judenstaates israel in
jerusalem
sehr bewegend
vertrauen in das heutige deutschland und
auch in die regierung haben und damit
vielleicht auch in mich und ich möchte
dass wir dieses vertrauen immer wieder
rechtfertigen
was sie darunter versteht demonstrierte
sie nicht nur bei vielen besuchen der
holocaust gedenkstätte yad vashem das
aus der verantwortung für die shoah
zuletzt eine tiefe freundschaft wurde
dank man hier vor allem merkel
in ihrer historischen rede in der
knesset 2008 erklärte sie die sicherheit
israels zur deutschen staatsräson das
schuf vertrauen zu einem anderen
deutschland merkel wiederholte es auch
heute deutschland ist nicht neutral wenn
es um die fragen der sicherheit israels
geht sondern die sicherheit israels ist
teil unserer staatsräson
dieses bekenntnis trug ihr quer durch
die israelische gesellschaft vertrauen
ein nicht nur im umgang mit dem
präsidenten-ehepaar für die israelis
steht merkel für die versöhnung zwischen
deutschen und juden zeigte mit dem
angebot israel als teil der deutschen
staatsräson zu
akzeptieren ihre bereitschaft
verantwortung für die vergangenheit zu
übernehmen das macht sie so populär hier
der status als gute freundin erlaubt ihr
aber auch deutliche kritik am umgang mit
dem atomprogramm des iran plädiert sie
für eine verhandlungslösung israel
notfalls für militärische gewalt und in
der palästina-frage hat merkel die
hoffnung auf zwei staaten noch nicht
aufgegeben da erscheint mir eine
zwei-staaten-lösung aus meiner
perspektive immer noch eine die richtig
ist wir haben über die alle aspekte der
siedlungspolitik noch nicht gesprochen
das ist dann vielleicht auch noch dem
abend vorbehalten denn durch die
siedlungspolitik ist natürlich die frage
der realisierbarkeit einer solchen
lösung schwieriger geworden die absage
von bennett fällt hart aus
wir haben die erfahrung gemacht dass mit
einem palästinensischen staat ein
terrorstaat entstehen würde
die natur dass dieser satz noch keine
politik ausmacht weiß bennett sowie die
kanzlerin weiß dass ihr einfluss
begrenzt ist und doch ihre stimme wird
gehört in israel
jetzt gibt es erstmal andere nachricht
des tages heinz da geht der weg erst mal
zu unseren österreichischen nachbarn der
dort steht jetzt der fahrplan für den
wechsel an der regierungsspitze
der bisherige aussenminister
schallenberg soll morgen vereidigt
werden und die nachfolge von sebastian
kurz als bundeskanzler antreten
schallenberg sprach heute auf den weg zu
bundespräsident van der bellen von einer
enorm herausfordernden aufgabe und seit
der van der bellen äußerte sich am abend
diese regierungskrise ist beendet morgen
mittag werde ich den neuen bundeskanzler
und einen neuen außenminister angeloben
und die arbeit für unser land kann
weitergehen
ich bedanke mich bei sebastian kurz mit
seinem schritt hat der schaden vom amt
für angehalten unter den wichtigen
beitrag geleistet dass die integrität
unserer institutionen geschützt wird
knapp drei monate nach der
flutkatastrophe in rheinland-pfalz und
nordrhein-westfalen hat bundespräsident
steinmeier das besonders getroffene
aartal besucht steinmeier informierte
sich über die schäden den wiederaufbau
und sprach mit betroffenen und helfern
allein im a teil kamen bei dem
hochwasser mehr als 130 menschen ums
leben insgesamt starben 183 menschen
zuvor war bundespräsident steinmeier in
darmstadt und verlieh den mit einer
halben million euro dotierten deutschen
umweltpreis an zwei wissenschaftler
ausgezeichnet wurden katrin böhning
gaese die daran arbeitet umwelt
veränderungen in ökosystemen in den
nächsten jahrzehnten so genau wie
möglich vorherzusagen
und hans joosten für seine jahrelange
forschung zur bedeutung der moore für
den klimaschutz
nach der knappen wahlniederlage von
ministerpräsident barbisch ist in
tschechien derzeit noch unklar wie es
weitergeht auch weil präsident sehe man
heute in ein krankenhaus eingeliefert
wurde details zur diagnose wurden nicht
mitgeteilt der präsident muss dem
parlament laut verfassung einen
kandidaten für das amt des
regierungschefs vorschlagen sehe man
könnte barbisch mit der
regierungsbildung beauftragen trotz des
wahlsiegs des konservativen
oppositionsbündnisses gemeinsam
in polen haben am abend landesweit
tausende menschen gegen ein umstrittenes
urteil des verfassungsgerichts
protestiert demnach verstoßen bestimmte
elemente des eu rechts gegen die
polnische verfassung viele
demonstrierende fordern zudem eine eu
freundlichere politik der regierung zu
den protesten aufgerufen hatte der
polnische oppositionsführer und
ehemalige eu ratspräsident donald tusk
zur coroner situation in deutschland und
zu den aktuellen zahlen das robert koch
institut meldet
7600 zwölf neue infektionen binnen 24
stunden
1448 mehr als am sonntag vergangener
woche es kamen 24 todesfälle hinzu die
sieben tage incidents liegt bei
66,1
das ist natürlich die durchschnitts
incidents unter den ungeimpften ist sie
vielerorts viel höher und es sind die
ungeimpften die jetzt auf den
intensivstationen liegen darunter auch
junge menschen und solche ohne
erkennbare vorerkrankungen hinzu kommen
die schwer einzuschätzenden
langzeitfolgen einer kurve erkrankung
aber noch nicht absehbar welche kosten
dadurch noch ob es gesundheitssystem
zukommen wer sich impfen lassen kann
aber nicht will wird künftig einen
kosten teil dieser pandemie selbst
tragen müssen nämlich den für die korona
schnelltests die sogenannten bürger
tests sie gibt es ab morgen nicht mehr
umsonst cornelia schiemenz berichtet
das war's am sonntagnachmittag schließt
das co testzentrum des drk in dresden
endgültig desinfizieren zusammenräumen
statistik machen sechs monate lang
konnten sich die dresdner hier kostenlos
auf corona testen lassen damit ist nun
schluss
dann wissen wir auch nicht tatsächlich
wie es denn dazu lauf wenn nur wenig
leute dann nur noch kommen und sich
vielleicht dann doch mehr entscheiden
dass es sich impfen lassen dann ist es
ein aspekt der wirtschaftlich dann so
nicht tragbar ist
260 menschen haben sich hier heute noch
mal kostenlos testen lassen fast 100
mehr als sonst das ab morgen jeder
selbst bezahlen muss trifft auf ein
gemischtes echo
impfen lassen sollten sich trotzdem ich
finde es nicht richtig
muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen weil wir ja
trotzdem bisher noch an kulturen am
leben teilnehmen und ich bin jetzt keine
gegnerin aber ich habe mich einfach dazu
entschieden das noch nicht zumachen
einkaufen restaurantbesuche
fitnessstudio es gilt die 3g regel
genesen geimpft getestet werden
ungeimpfte damit ausgegrenzt vom
gesellschaftlichen leben wenn sie ihre
tests zukünftig selber zahlen müssen
nein sie können sich jederzeit impfen
lassen oder eben halt kostenpflichtig
testen lassen das ist der ausschluss
ihrer freiheits entscheidung die müssen
weg kommen dass wir sagen freiheits
entscheidung ja aber die vorteile
gewinne ich und die nachteile perlich ab
in der dresdner altmarkt galerie bleibt
das testzentrum eines privaten
betreibers offen 24 eur 99 wird der
korona schnelltest hier kosten rigoros
soll kontrolliert werden wer weiter
anspruch auf den kostenlosen test hat
bei unter 18 jährigen den ausweis bei
leuten die ihre quarantäne durch den
test verkürzen müssen dann den nachweis
vom gesundheitsamt und leute die sich
aus gesundheitlichen gründen nicht
impfen lassen konnten handelten
ärztliches attest
meißen an der elbe ein touristenmagnet
viele restaurant und hotel betreiber
ärgern sich über die 3g regel die sie
umsetzen müssen sowie kathrin herzog
chefin im goldenen anker sie meint der
staat ihnen die verantwortung zu das
spaltet die gesellschaft spalte zwischen
familien und das ist schwierig und ich
schuld sein wenn das dann so auftritt
gewinnt von kyle treiben die rede ist
dann treiben die ungeimpften die
freiwillig ungeimpften und diesen teil
in die gesellschaft und nicht diese
maßnahmen das ende der kostenlosen
corona tests für jedermann wird in
katrin herzog ist dafür allerdings
befürchtet sie umsatzeinbußen und so
manche neue streiterei an den tischen
ihres restaurants
und jetzt nochmal eins mit dem sport in
der formel 1 heute großer preis der
türkei gewonnen hat das rennen in
istanbul valtteri bottas formaxx
vorstand und sergio perez
max was daten übernimmt damit wieder die
führung in der gesamtwertung von
weltmeister lewis hamilton der fünfter
wurde
fußball bundestrainer hansi flick will
sich mit der nationalmannschaft
schnellstmöglich für die
weltmeisterschaft qualifizieren das ziel
hatte heute noch mal deutlich gemacht
vor dem qualifikations spielen morgen
gegen dort mazedonien beim
abschlusstraining fehlte nur antonio
rüdiger der wegen rückenschmerzen
pausieren musste manuel neuer dagegen
ist einsatzbereit konnte nach
leistenproblemen wieder mitmachen in
nord mazedonien soll vorzeitig das
wm-ticket gebucht werden wollen eine
mannschaft auf dem platz haben die
miteinander fußballspiel die von enormer
aktivität geprägt ist und wir wollen das
spiel morgen gewinnen wir haben gesagt
wir wollen so schnell als möglich uns
qualifizieren für diese
weltmeisterschaft und da gehört dieses
spiel morgen auch dazu nach einer
intensiven trainingswoche und sieben
tagen in hamburg sind sie am nachmittag
abgereist ziel nord mazedonien und drei
punkte in
vielen zentralistisch regierten ländern
dominiert die hauptstadt ja alles der
rest ist quasi provinz in deutschland
ist es umgekehrt bei uns ist die
hauptstadt in vieler hinsicht
provinziell natürlich nicht kulturell
aber politisch und administrativ das
berlin aber noch nicht mal in der lage
war wahlen zu organisieren das war
trotzdem ein kleiner schock das
komplette chaos das jetzt zu
urlaubsbeginn am ber ausbrach das kann
hingegen niemanden verwundern der diesen
flughafen häufiger nutzen muss hätte es
kroner nicht gegeben wäre das schon
längst aufgefallen und hatte bundesweit
schlagzeilen gemacht scheinbar
funktioniert hat er nur solange es kaum
fluggäste gab
wenn das schon leyen auf anhieb erkennen
können um sollte das auch profis
aufgefallen sein egal hauptsache das
ding ist endlich auf der des berlin
christel apple macht sich gedanken über
unsere hauptstadt
was ist typisch berlin
der fernsehturm und eine
millionenmetropole ohne sperrstunde aber
mit dem großen talent zu scheitern
dieses wochenende am neuen flughafen ber
herbstferienbeginn stundenlanges
anstehen nichts geht mehr nicht wenige
verpassen ihren urlaubsflug
urlaub zu ende bevor er begonnen hat
aber auch wählen geht nicht so einfach
vor allem wenn wahllokale geschlossen
werden weil keine stimmzettel mehr da
sind berlin blamiert sich so gut es kann
zwei unabhängige beobachter reden
klartext
absurdistan ist mir zu niedlich für
diesen vorgang das zu sagen es ist ein
skandal dass man die wahlen nicht hat
reibungslos organisieren können und
offenkundig auch nicht weil es erinnert
mich an indien diese riesen bürokratie
und man man ist verrückt geworden man
müsste wirklich so ganz ganz langsam
einen guten roman mitnehmen das mache
ich nächstes mal und dann sich in die
schlange stellen und lesen typisch
berlin wer einen personalausweis
benötigt braucht viel glück und
monatelange geduld eine bezahlbare
wohnung ist wie ein sechser im lotto
nach dem gescheiterten mieten deckel
sollen nun enteignungen helfen tja und
die versprochene verkehrswende eine neue
ampel brauchte in berlin mahlsdorf dank
organisierter unzuständigkeit 25 jahre
jetzt blickt sie
man sieht dass mit dem flughafen man
sieht dass das man in so viele orte
nicht mit der mit der kreditkarte
bezahlen kann man sieht dass die straßen
sehr oft sehr schmutzig sind es gibt
sehr viel was nicht so perfekt läuft in
berlin ich glaube aber dass in berlin
über besonders deutlich probleme des
ganzen landes sichtbar werden das ist
eine infrastruktur gibt die dringend
instand gesetzt und vor allem
modernisiert werden muss nicht nur in
berlin aber in berlin merkt man es
besonders deutlich in der hauptstadt
weilt sich alles zusammen eine
ausgebaute verwaltung ein dschungel an
vorschriften und das berühmte berliner
motto behörden ping pong genannt was ist
die zentrale aufgabe für den neuen senat
den alltag in dieser stadt besser zu
organisieren dass ich die wichtigste
aufgabe aber ich mag das weil dieses
chaos gehört zu berlin und berlin darf
nicht so glatt werden kann die
hauptstadt auch anders nichts ist
unmöglich
hier sind schon ganz anderen gefallen
und das ist typisch berlin
und jetzt zu guter letzt unser
sonntägliche ausblick auf die neue woche
an der glaser hat ihn zusammengestellt
in der neuen woche wollen spd grüne und
fdp ihre sondierungsgespräche vertiefen
am montag ist das erste von drei treffen
geplant das inhaltliche abtasten in
richtung ampel geht weiter ob sie auf
grün springt hängt davon ab wie
kompromissbereit die parteien sind
am dienstag werden in rom die g20
zusammen kommen der italienische
regierungschef mario draghi hat dazu
eingeladen um eine humanitäre
katastrophe in afghanistan zu verhindern
nach der machtübernahme der taliban
steht das land vor dem wirtschaftlichen
kollaps laut un sind 14 millionen
menschen von hunger bedroht der
umstrittenen afghanistan-einsatz der
bundeswehr wird am tag darauf in berlin
mit einem großen zapfenstreich gewürdigt
werden
seit über vier wochen streiken in berlin
pflegekräfte und hebammen für bessere
arbeitsbedingungen
der streik ist ein hilferuf aus einem
oft kritisierten system beim deutschen
pflegetag 20 21 werden von praxis
politik und wirtschaft lösungswege
gesucht
nach lösungen sucht auch die junge union
beim sogenannten deutschlandtag soll die
bundestagswahl aufgearbeitet werden die
reden der beiden parteivorsitzenden
laschet und söder am samstag werden mit
spannung erwartet und
noch die wetteraussichten zum start in
die neue woche morgen ziehen von
nordwesten her wolken heran und
zeitweise regnet es etwas südlich des
mains bleibt es meist trocken an den
alpen hält sich länger nebel die
temperatur erreicht sehen bis 16 grad
die kommenden tage werden unbeständig
vor allem am dienstag gibt es viele
schauer und wind und es wird recht kühl
am mittwoch liegt die höchsttemperatur
bei nur 4 bis 13 grad
das war es von uns weiter geht es mit
einem highlight für alle klassik freunde
und freundinnen die verleihung des opus
classic 20 21 und um 0.15 gibt es dann
die nächste heute express und hier
wollen sich morgen claus kleber und
gundula gause auch sie auf wiedersehen
auf wiedersehen